revenons à la deuxième journée du procès
public en appel de patrick dils devant
la cour d'assises dès mineurs à lyon
seize ans après les faits une jeune
femme a confirmé sa première déposition
ces témoignages donnent en effet une
indication de leur du double meurtre
un témoignage capital pour les parties
civiles en revanche ils cassent
véritablement la libye de patrick dils
compte rendu d'audience clément
weill-raynal salah g face à face les
avocats de la défense et des parties
civiles tente inlassablement de
reconstituer de comprendre
quinze ans après les faits ce qui a pu
se passer le 28 septembre 1986 le long
d'une voie ferrée de montigny-lès-metz
c'est là qu'avaient été découverts dans
la soirée
les corps de cyril et alexandre mais à
quelle heure a eu lieu le double meurtre
entre 17h30 et 19h a révélé l'autopsié à
17h30 patrick dils a un alibi à 19
heures il n'en a plus
le dernier témoignage de témoignages
mathis dit que les enfants riez fort
j'étais pas comme ça en cachette
derrière à jouer
il parlait il joue et irriguer il
s'amusait et à partir de 17h15 mystère
on n'entend plus du tout les enfants les
enfants devaient être chez eux ils n'y
sont pas la mer sa folle qu'est ce qui
s'est passé monsieur entre 17h15 et 19
heures
mais l'accusation et les parties civiles
s'appuie sur un tout autre témoignage
celui d'isabelle deschamps une voisine
qui doit sa fenêtre avait entendu un
hurlement d'enfants peu avant 19 heures
c'est son témoignage
confronté à l'emploi du temps de patrick
dils qui avait orienté les soupçons des
enquêteurs sur ce dernier
madame deschamps un témoignage qui ne
peut pas être remis en doute c'est
certain qu'elle a entendu des cris des
cris qui l'ont suffisamment alertée pour
qu'elle aille voir son amie pour qu'elle
descende aider la mère qui est en train
de rechercher ses enfants parce que
c'était un clic il l'a bouleversée
pressé de questions par les enquêteurs
qui s'appuyait sur le témoignage
d'isabelle deschamps patrick dils avait
fini par avouer avec force détails le
double meurtre avant de se rétracter
patrick dils que l'on sent peut-être un
peu moins à l'aise dans le box qu'à
l'ouverture du procès devra au cours des
prochaines audiences s'expliquer sur les
raisons de ces aveux